hi there hi hey doing I'm doing good
it's a weird time for everybody but it's
a great time for us to be able to
connect like this so thank you for
taking the time to chat with me I want
to say congratulations on everything
what an incredible past few years you
have had I hid who I was for so long I
really didn't come out openly until I
was like 21 22 years old it's such an
empowering feeling to just let it out
and be you and live your truth and
where's my social media platform and
with the WWE behind me I feel like if
you have a voice you need to use it I
look at myself you know before I was
calling before I was open and I always
looked for representation in Hollywood
on television and in music you know um
just as a closeted gay girl you you look
for that right you want to have someone
in the spotlight or in the public eye
that thinks similarly as you do and you
know there wasn't much of that growing
up and I'm from a very small farms town
in South New Jersey and so I didn't know
one gay person or anybody from the LGBTQ
community from age birth to 20 you know
it's 18 maybe so it was hard for me to
accept who I was because I didn't know
that it was okay and I didn't know that
it was really a thing besides Ellen
DeGeneres I mean that was like the only
public figure you know so it is cool to
be that person for hopefully this
generation and especially in wrestling a
world that you know we don't see much of
it as well it's really surreal to stand
here right now knowing that three years
ago today I wasn't even openly gay
and nobody except for my mom and my dad
knew that I was gay so to be here on a
float that has my name on it with my
best friends my girlfriend my family
celebrating the fact that I'm gay is
surreal so thank you guys so much and I
love you all looking back now do you
wish you had done it even sooner or was
it just the timing that you need yeah so
I'm the same person I don't ever regret
anything I'm very firm believer in
everything happening for a reason timing
being a huge part of life in general
being able to share that story and hope
that it you know can resonate in
somebody else's mind and heart and help
them make the decision earlier is
definitely a wish of mine um but yeah my
journey took its turns for a reason and
you know brought me here something lost
seriously I was creeping your Twitter
today and some back and or it's getting
pretty heated never got it fired desire
was never about us oh my god week after
week I came out to your entrance music
waving around your stupid magazines my
face was blurred out in the damn
Richards you couldn't even see me trying
to share camera time with the golden
goddess excuse me I literally almost
just gagged I just want to know if you
think that relationship can ever be
repaired at this point no it won't be no
no not a chance
like nothing [ __ ] I mean it's until she
can grasp and understand and have
remorse for the fact that I've been
living in her shadow us for the past
four years I mean to the extent of she
just had no care in the world that you
know I was trying to be successful as
well all she cared about herself very
self-centered and you know she allowed
it to affect us personally whether it
was like I said me getting blurred out
in the frigging entrance for two years
straight you know she never fought for
anything different you never cared to
speak up and so yeah I just don't need
something like that in my life and don't
worry Karma's a you-know-what but I mean
I even just died and again like having
that representation tell me about
rainbow rock you fly about strongly
about doing a clothing line like this
representation is so important because
you know for us now we're open we're out
it you know life is butterflies and
rainbows no pun intended but look you we
have is important to remember back
to how we used to feel and there's so
many people that still feel that way I
feel so strongly like I want to scream
at the top of my lungs like it's okay to
be you don't be afraid as long as you're
safe and you have a place to sleep at
night I say do it you know and that's my
that's kind of been my motto and so this
line rainbow love is it's a very
emotional line one of the first t-shirts
that drop on the back has the suicide
prevention hotline and it says you are
not alone and that's just kind of my
message you're not alone oh hey there if
you want more LGBTQ news and exclusive
interviews click Subscribe or watch
these videos